okay so if you've been watching the
program for a while if you listen to the
show you know that I have no delusions
about blue states or liberal cities or
just all Democrats or whatever being
clean of racism so to speak to differing
degrees even our bluest cities and most
progressive institutions and most
self-described liberal people still
harbor racist prejudice and beliefs and
I've done interviews about the
significant racism that existed
historically
in our broadcast city of Boston in New
York City where I used to live I've
talked about how segregated these cities
still are to this day and even on
college campuses liberal college
campuses in liberal cities in blue
states there is still plenty of racism
and I have a story for you today from
the hometown of the David Pakman show
Northampton Massachusetts where we
started and specifically from Smith
College which is an extremely liberal
College where I have both family and
friends that work as faculty and staff
and the story has gone completely
national and the story is that of a
black student who was eating lunch in a
common room and she had the police
called on her by a Smith College
employee because she looked reportedly
out of place I'm talking about
uma knut a I hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly who's a sophomore at Smith
College and teaches chemistry to high
schoolers over the summer she was
reading and eating lunch in the Tyler
house dorms dining hall I've been in the
Tyler house many times a completely
normal place where people exist in the
world like you would expect on any
college campus and sometimes consume
food for the purposes of synthesizing it
into nutrients to Harbor the power of
life right completely normal activity
that we all participate in and next
thing you know a police officer is
walking in with a Smith College employee
and they tell her they're wondering why
she's there police told her that an
employee had called them about what it
was initially described as a suspicious
black man of course she's a woman and
now the college has both apologized to
her and has suspended or put on leave
pending an investigation the employee
who made the
all who as far as I saw a couple hours
ago still has not been identified
publicly and it's also not clear exactly
what was suspicious about eating lunch
officer the food appeared to be
extremely spicy and well dressed please
please hurry up the student says she did
nothing wrong she wasn't making noise
she wasn't bothering anyone she was just
black as she describes it so to be clear
we're not talking here about
institutional racism it's not a lesson
about Smith College being liberal and
for black lives matter and whatever else
but still being racist as an institution
as far as we know right now barring the
the news that this was related to some
kind of policy this was just one
employee but it's just another reminder
that there's racism everywhere even in
blue states even in blue cities even at
liberal progressive colleges this
individual could be anybody they could
have any political beliefs I have no
idea since we don't know exactly who it
is right now but the other really odd
thing is that to call the police about
this instead of just walking up to the
person and saying hey who are you
it implies either that the Smith
employee was really genuinely
intimidated by this woman which okay
would be a little odd or that they were
cowards and that they said I'm gonna try
to get somebody else to do the dirty
work that I need done but even that
element of it doesn't make any sense
yeah I think all the blame goes to the
employee you can't really even blame the
police officer necessarily because
they're responding to a call they got to
investigate I would just hope that at
the end of the conversation there the
police officer would instruct the
employee to investigate a little bit on
their own or at least not make such an
impulsive decision there is one other
possibility which is as I mentioned the
report was allegedly about a suspicious
black male is it possible that the
person that the police ended up speaking
to who was this woman was not the person
about whom the report was originally
filed like it's such a basic question
and I've not seen follow up on that I
don't know like was this even the person
who the report was about I don't know
but the impact so far is that
the student has been significantly
traumatized by this understandably the
employing question has been placed on
leave and as always we get into can we
really attribute this to personal racism
was the individual who called the police
personally racist I don't know the
underlying circumstances are that an
employee at a prestigious expensive
private school thought that a black
student eating lunch looked out of place
was it their clothing that made them
look out of place was it the food that
they had was it their race I don't know
that we can really know for sure we
always hear the rights say you can't
know a hundred percent what's in
someone's head but I think it's
perfectly reasonable to talk about race
as a factor here well yeah I mean
usually there's no control group to
compare it to and we hear about these
stories it's one incident yeah because
it's just one incident but there are
white students I'm sure eating lunch in
that common Hall every single day and I
take it that they're not getting the
police called on them I've not heard
about any such incidents that's a good
question though and it's important you
know I think at the at the end of the
day what's important is don't allow the
right to shut down an exploration of
race as a motivating factor because the
right is very quick to say you can't
accuse people of racism unless you know
it definitively there could have been
other reasons why the police were called
on this particular individual and to
attribute racism to someone when you're
not a hundred and ten percent sure that
that's what it is that's wrong okay that
may be but they can't say that you can't
talk about race as a factor here to
attribute specific we don't even know
who the person was but don't allow the
topic of race to be suppressed by those
individuals yeah the worst thing in the
world is to be accused of being racist
so says the right wing yes that's a
common refrain that we hear from them
we'll see ultimately what else we learn
about the circumstances underlying this